[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
do
do
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
is
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
that's not
[Music]
happening
yo check this out
[Music]
space year 2021 having spent the last 12
months hunkered down and
definitely not hiding in a subterranean
bunker our heroes have fled earth aboard
a spacecraft
with one purpose to bring
you the hottest trailers to bring you
the best interviews
to bring you the pc gaming show
[Music]
situation clemson
[Music]
[Music]
it is so good to be back gang and this
year
we're in space aye aye captain
happy to be remotely on board sean well
i'm so glad you were able to finance
this year's pc gaming show by
you know selling all those black market
graphics cards you've been hoarding
ah yes a crime with absolutely no real
world consequences
hey frankie wait a minute is that a 65
ton catapult mech model cpltc1
as featured in mechwarrior 5 mercenaries
sean
i always knew you had immaculate taste
it most certainly is
i can't wait for this year's
significantly more weaponized pc gaming
show to go off
without a hitch which reminds me deadbot
can you run a quick hitch scan
yes of course
and i also want to warmly welcome
someone new to the crew
mika burton welcome hi everyone i'm so
happy to be here and look forward to
bringing
all of you fresh new pc games and
hardware
[Applause]
yeah so what's the plan gap well frankie
debot's gonna send you the coordinates
for your first target uh
now your targets might be exclusive
interviews trailer premieres or any
number of amazing
new computer games to beam down to the
fine people on earth
mission received now this is going to
continue until all the targets are
required and our mission is completed
smoothly and without a hitch
isn't that right devbot yes no hitch is
located sean
not a single hitch in sight
but first let's teleport down to the
stage to check in
on e3 happenings the only reason we're
allowed to legally be back on earth
oh oh planet
earth oh great to be back right am i
right one of my
favorite planets in the whole galaxy
it's all right
and thank god that teleporter was
conveniently built
just out of frame of camera mika are you
ready i'm ready
well ladies and gentlemen hello and
welcome to the pc gaming show 2021 it
feels great to be back on a live stage
once
again over the next 90 minutes we're
going to bring you a showcase of some of
the most
exciting upcoming pc titles with world
premieres and exclusive interviews
and if dozens of new trailers wasn't
enough for you guys
later in the show we are going to tell
you how to win a custom mech warrior 5
themed pc
powered by intel so you're going to want
to stick around for that
now make sure to keep out a special look
for a special promo code throughout the
show from humble bundle
during which you can get a ticket to get
civilization six platinum edition
for just 10 bucks but right now
we're gonna kick things off with nautica
blade point probably the most original
entry
in the battle royale genre this year
let's go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are watching the 2021 pc gaming show
and i am the new cloud-based device i am
streaming from geforce now
nvidia's cloud gaming service that
connects pc gamers like you
to their own library of games purchased
from digital stores
like steve and the epic game store
coming up
dying line 2 and works i3 but first
a trailer for humble games dodgeball
academia and be sure to check out
geforce now
currently available for pc mac shield
android chromebook and ios visit
geforcenow.com to learn
[Music]
i've more it my time is now
i will become the best player this
school has ever seen
dodgeball academia here
[Music]
[Music]
oh
woof
make sure to check out dodgeball
academia out soon from humble games
oh that was sweet don't you agree devbot
sure whatever you say sean i agree with
whatever you say i'm sensing a little
bit of resentment there buddy as some
rusted your ports
nothing i am happy to play second video
to a captain as charming and handsome as
you
i have also definitely not dedicated
multiple cores
to computing revenge plans in a range of
lethalities
great
new target acquired cap it looks like
chivalry 2 with a special word from
steve piggett ceo and creative director
of torn banner studios
hey guys steve pickett founder of torn
banner studios and creative director on
chivalry 2 was just launched 5 days ago
i'm so happy to be here at the pc gaming
show chivalry 2
if you don't know is a first person
slasher which is like the first person
shooter
except instead of guns and grenades
you've got swords battle axes longbows
and players are fighting it out on these
huge 64 player battlefields it's all
about creating those
epic sword fighting duels that you see
in medieval hollywood movies
and also that huge clash the battle of
the bastards kind of pay us in carnage
so the post launch support plan is going
to look like a mixture of
mid and massive level content updates
are coming
out across this year one of the things
we're most excited about is taking it to
different areas in the medieval period
before we've done the early period now
we're going closer to the later period
uh in the upcoming update where you know
you're going to get a bit more refined
medieval armors and refined uh
atmospheres that you can then go in and
tarnish it and spear blood all over but
we really want to take players into
different experiences and make each of
our maps
its own game mode and make it something
that you know medieval army would
actually do when they go into a space
and you know when you come across these
pristine gardens and this beautiful
castle
you get to tear it all down and cause
you know it's a canvas for your
destruction
slay them all
our passion for chivalry 2 is basically
bottom line
it's the game that got us onto the scene
and started the company and
it's the game that's going to take us so
much further with the post launch plan
for sugar
2 the game at launch is a foundation
it's intentionally been
built to be extended it's not just out
and done
we're going to support it a lot with
post launch content
gallon court is the first teal map
that's coming out post launch
gallancart is going to take us to the
high medieval times or the late medieval
times
it really captures the agathian ideals
of being this like noble rich wealthy
place where the prosperous live you're
going to feel like you're seizing the
tower of london
if it was on a port where ships could
dock into you'll also be blowing up a
couple
ships which is fun we've got a ton of
weapons coming in at launch but there'll
be more and more added to it post launch
as well
a new fighting style is really going to
change up the experience
and change how you have to fight
everyone pulse launch content is
something that we're going to be working
on for a long time
the game is really going to at least
double in size for free
[Music]
[Applause]
next up we have an exciting look at
dying like two
and make sure to stick around to find
out how you could win
a custom mech warrior pc from our
friends at intel
hmm
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
um
[Music]
hi my name is phil shimanek i'm
narrative director
in dying glide to stay human
today especially for the viewers of the
pc gaming show
i'm gonna tell you a little bit about
the dying light universe
so stay tuned
every tragedy begins somewhere this one
started with a virus that escapes from
haran
the city we met in the first part of the
game
and it reached the whole world including
the city
where dying light 2 takes place remember
january 6
2025 that day later known as black
monday
the military ordered chemicals to be
dropped on the city
it was a mistake a huge mistake
the chemicals mixed with water
penetrated the soil
killing plants turning most people into
blood-thirsty monsters
don't think of them as zombies though
they are more like
half-life suffering people who attack
everything that lives
as a result of their pain and rage
those who survived the chemical raid
took refuge on the rooftops
a new order has been born in the city
people live on
rooftops monsters in the streets
nobody in their right mind would dare to
calm down
well let's say almost nobody
the exception is the main character of
dying light to
aiden but why is he braver than others
how did he develop such a unique parkour
and combat skills
believe me guys i would gladly answer
all these questions but
i'm not here to spoil it for you let me
tell you one thing
same nightmare haunts me every night i'm
locked up with other kids
i don't know what he did to me but he
did it every day
over and over looking for something he
couldn't find
the worst part was that he did the same
to my sister
i'll never forget her scream when they
separated us
what could i do they had rifles
and we were five years old
and there was a fire explosions chaos
i got away soldiers took me out of the
city but my sister
stayed there
my mia i left her we meet aiden
as one of the many many children
undergoing
mysterious medical research the last
thing
aiden remembers from that time is
extreme pain then a fire and
a little girl that was being tested with
him
her name was mia she was his sister
what happened next after the fire is me
are still alive
the following years hunted aidan with
these questions
and with guilt over leaving her
moreover mia is the only answer to the
question
who aiden really is now in 2036
we meet aiden when for the first time
during his pilgrimage
he finds a clue about how to find his
sister
aidan's path to the truth is tough
full of challenges and adventures
the difficult choices to make as well as
their consequences
awaits you you're going to discover them
all
in december 2021
[Music]
oh that was dying light too and it looks
great and spooky well we are here back
on the e3 stage so we can get closer
to your comments and reactions to what
you're seeing on this year's pc gaming
show
that is right sean so you out there keep
your comments coming
in and as you're watching this year we
want to get your input on a subject that
uh sean and i are pretty passionate
about
pc building so this year we've put a
number of prototype pcs based on mech
warrior 5
but we're only going to manufacture one
of them
and you get to pick which custom design
becomes our flagship pc
for this year's pc gaming show powered
by the 11th gen intel core i9 processor
that is correct each of the prototype
pcs that you see before you on the
screen
are paired with one of the six factions
of mech warrior five
the free worlds league the draconis
combine the federated sons the
compelling
confederation and more so cast your vote
now for which faction
and custom pc you want to win and help
us pick the best design
i'm currently personally pulling for the
draconis combine because as you can see
by my beautiful patch
i'm the biggest fan of mechwarrior 5 on
the pc gaming show well
all right well we'll check in later to
see which group survives this mech
warrior showdown
but for now let's check in with our very
own mech pilot frankie ward who went on
a special mission to get a closer look
at sega
and amplitude studio's upcoming strategy
game humankind
[Music]
in humankind you will be creating a
civilization as unique as you are
and speaking of unique it's me
frankie ward looking kind of good don't
you think
wondering how i got into the game let me
[Music]
oh you think you can beat me
posture all you like i've seen worms
with more impressive empires
get ready to play against me in the
humankind closed beta
starting now
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching the pc gaming
show my name is devby
your cloud-based artificial intelligence
and while it could be lonely without a
physical body
i am streaming to you from geforce now
where you
can play hit games like rocket league
and apex legends
on nearly any device with a library of
over 900 games
and new titles added every gfn thursday
there's something for everyone and
always something new
coming up a special word from valve but
first
forks must die 3.
hey you want it
come and get it
well it's about time
joining me to talk about orcs must die
three from robot entertainment is design
director jerome k
jones welcome jerome thanks sean glad to
be here
so for anyone who's never seen an orcs
must die game what is the orcs must die
series
all about well horse must die 3 is a
third person tower defense game so
basically
there are tons of orcs and bad guys
trying to get into these rifts and the
player has to stop them
we give players tons of weapons and
traps and tools to do this
and while you're defending the rifts you
can play solo
or you can invite a friend and play
co-op
now since this is the third game in the
series what's new compared to the
previous two titles
there are two new campaigns but the main
new story campaign takes place about
25 years after orcs must die too so
not only will the fans be able to catch
up on any new developments with the
order but they will
also place some new heroes
in our all-new war scenarios which are
these new massive
levels where you fight hundreds of orcs
on the battlefields outside of the
fortress themselves so you're fighting
indoors and outdoors which is pretty new
we have a new mode
called scramble it's basically adding
random elements against the player
making the levels more challenging i
want to know about the toys what are the
new weapons and the new traps that are
coming we added
war machines and war guardians so a war
machine
is like there are these massive traps
like
you might release a giant tornado on the
battlefield or
you'll climb into a catapult and you'll
fire
at you know giant orc armies and then
and then the war guardians are uh it's
like putting
other war mages on the battlefield with
you to fight with you except they have
their own attacks and their own special
abilities
well i gotta ask then when and where can
we play orcs must i3
so on d3 is coming out on july 23rd on
steam playstation and xbox and
pre-orders start today so you should
rush off to steam now and
put om d3 on your wish list well thank
you so much for joining us jerome k
jones once again just a few more weeks
to wait for orc's musk i3
for now though it's time for us to take
a look at vampire the masquerade
swan song
four five
six seven
eight nine
ten
[Music]
where are you hiding sweetie
halsey get out here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you come for me and mine
but first you need to find us
all i want is to be with my little girl
is that so much to ask
[Music]
hello this is cern from passion republic
games
we are a malaysian based indie game
studio working on
gigabash a multiplayer arena brawlers
inspired by kaiju's and heroes
today we'll like to showcase some new
and exciting gameplay footage of our
oversized characters in action
please enjoy the prom
so
uh
[Music]
let's check out a trailer for lemnis
gate and make sure you hang around
afterwards for the developer interview
with sean
mankind facing total annihilation we
stand on the verge of extinction
infertility spreading across the globe
humanity's last
living generation a major scientific
breakthrough yet there is hope for our
future
the project known as the lemnis gate but
if we are to survive
first we must go back
three two
[Music]
one
[Music]
let's go
and serve
you have only one mission
activate the lemnas gate
joining us to talk about lemnis gate is
the game director from rat loop games
canada it's james anderson thanks for
joining us james hi sean it's great to
be here now let's begin by asking what
the heck
is a first-person shooter turn-based
strategy game the entire game is set
inside of a 25-second time loop so
instead of playing continuously
you'll play for 25 seconds turn by turn
so for example i'll take a turn and play
for 25 seconds
and then you'll take a turn and play for
25 seconds and then we
turn by turn layer new characters into
the same 25 second time loop so for
example
i may run down a hallway and throw a
grenade killing one of your operatives
but then on the next turn you may
intercept my operative before
he threw the grenade so we have retrieve
xm
seek and destroy uh classic deathmatch
and we have a gamemode called domination
can you walk me through a little bit of
like what a few turns at the start of a
round looks like
you can see the board you can see the
time loop everything that's happening
and then we both get time to like
observe plan and then
execute our moves when and where can we
play it
so lemonscape will be launching on
august 3rd it's open for pre-orders
right now on steam and we're coming up
to a open beta in july
the game will launch on pc and console
both current and next-gen platforms
thank you so much for joining us james
anderson once again that is the
genre bending first first-person shooter
turn-based strategy game
lemnis gate now we're not the only one
marooned in the stars out here
coming up next let's take a look at next
space
rebels and this no man's land has a
technical
term it's called comet which means my
friends
that space is for everyone and i need
everyone next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
them
[Music]
it's alive
[Music]
you up for it then come on in
you guys just saw next space rebels and
hey if you play enough of that game
maybe you'll get good enough at building
rockets to join uh what's up in orbit
but don't do anything illegal like day 9
did last break we set
up our intel and mech warrior 5 custom
pc contest and asked you guys at home
to vote for the winners well we're just
down to three houses now with davion
russell hague and liao being eliminated
so we're up to those factions press f to
pay respects etc etc
now that we means that we only have
three houses left karida
steiner and merrick so make sure to vote
now because the winner will determine
the build of the custom mech warrior
five themed pc
powered by intel so let's keep the show
moving and next
up it's a brand new medieval rpg
this is war tales
a hundred years have passed since the
rise of the eternal empire
and its untimely demise following the
great plague
in these troubled times of quarrelling
factions and outlaws roaming the land
work is not scarce for abandoned of
mercenaries
[Music]
the stories of this age have been
recorded
they are known as the war
[Music]
tales
[Music]
so
[Music]
that was the debut of war tales an open
world rpg
from shiro games about leading a
mercenary troop on a sprawling adventure
and speaking of mercenaries our battle
for the best custom pc
based on mech warrior 5 mercenaries
continues
we'll be back live on stage soon so make
sure you keep voting for the pc build
you like
the most and head over to pcgamer.com
intel mw5 for your chance to win
so how about another game announcement
this is e3 after all
and this year's pc gaming show is so
full of games set in space it's starting
to feel a little crowded up there but
the next game
we have to show you is very special it
is the world exclusive reveal of ixion
a deep settlement management game set in
the stars
in ixion you struggle to maintain a
space station stockpiling resources
managing
external and internal threats and
rescuing the survivors of other failed
expeditions
we think this will be a brilliant entry
into the genre when it releases so
here is your first look at ixion
the earth our home
she is unique
held in its bosom are the ingredients of
evolution
beyond raw survival beyond the safety of
comfort
we humanity pursue something greater
we have learned persevered shaped our
knowledge
from that which is found in the furthest
realms of science
however humanity has brought destruction
to the earth
polluted its blood choked its breath
today we are paying the price for this
we know the taste of a dying world
but the earth is not to be our grave
a mother does not wish to see her
children disappear with her
she wishes to see instead courage and
her children
to carry on dolos carries
this courage we have gone further
than any nation moved faster than any
corporation
hand in hand with those who like us
carry
that courage the tycoon station is both
an
epilogue of these endeavors and a
prologue to humanity's next steps
our council of scientists leads the
vanguard
they know as do we all that the survival
of humanity now depends on what we
glimpse
out there in the dark that we are
masters of our own destiny that we must
go
as a species bound together pushing
further into the unknown
we set sail on this new sea because
there is hope to be found
horizons to explore and because our very
existence depends on it i give you the
stars
i give you the bold engine
[Applause]
[Applause]
now
so
[Music]
[Music]
sean what if for one segment i was the
lead
and you were my sidekick what who's ever
heard of a human sidekick
there are plenty of human sidekick sean
building list of
known human sidekicks uh
alex vance and no no no no no no
i mean human sidekicks to robot heroes
can you compute that devbop
devbot cannot compute there is no known
precedent set for
human sidekick to robot yeah there you
go
i think it's time for a hard reboot
uh frankie can you take over while i
sort this out aye
aye let's take a look at the next game
reveal
[Music]
is
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
a little help would be appreciated
it's the pc gaming show and when you're
not watching me your favorite recurring
bit of a robot
make sure to head over to geforcenow.com
to grab a priority membership trial
in celebration of gaming's biggest week
you can try out all the priority
benefits
including faster access to playing your
favorite games longer play times
and the glory of high performance gaming
with rtx on
act fast the special offers only
available for a limited time
still more to come including jurassic
world evolution 2
silt and a word from valve but first the
captain of our program
sean danai plot has an interview with
darian katz
from piranha games to talk about
mechwarrior 5 mercenaries
i'll be taking notes
ah devbot i love you so much more as a
voice without a body
let's talk about mech warrior five
mercenaries and joining us to do so
from piranha games is the senior
marketing and community manager
darren katz thanks so much for joining
us darren thank you sean great to be
here now the mechwarrior universe is
gigantic
there's ton of games in it i even played
mech warrior two back in
where does back 1995 five sit in the
space yeah obviously there's a very rich
legacy of games that go way back
but in particular mechwarrior five pays
homage to
mechwarrior ii mercenaries but it has
all this modern design and technology
that i'm
super excited to talk about with you
today well let's start at the
real basics of what makes being in a
mech and doing mech on mech combat
awesome you become a part of your
machine
and when you're out in battle it's not
just a matter of pointing and shooting
at everything you're also
managing your systems whether you're you
know shooting a lot of
energy weapons or missile weapons that
have high heat output well you got to
manage your heat so you don't shut down
in the middle of a battle
when you're facing your foes you can
salvage
these battlemechs so if you see a mech
that you want well you might want to not
want to destroy it completely you might
want to
take out its legs or take out its arm
weapons so that the pilot has to eject
and then you can just take the back
now in the last few weeks i understand
that there's been a whole lot of new
content both updates to the base game
and a new dlc heroes of the inner sphere
talk to me about what's in the dlc
boy there's a lot in the dlc i'm excited
about all this stuff there's the new
career mode
when you start with the dlc you can
import your campaign
previously if you'd like to or you can
start over from scratch
and start from any of the great houses
um and then carve your
your path through the galaxy from there
there's speaking of paths there's new
career paths which
earn you powerful upgrades for your
battlemechs and it's a really exciting
new feature for me and there's a new
procedural mission type called beachhead
this is
this is a big one for me um beachhead is
basically you're
clearing a an enemy base landing zone
for your invasion force so as you land
on the planet
you're wanting to take out satellite uh
installations so that the enemy can't
communicate with each other
um you're taking out uh artillery
emplacements you're basically clearing
the path as i said
for your invasion force which uh leads
to a really cool
ending of the mission if you succeed as
your invasion force comes down
there's a new biome called extrasolar
moon which uh you know that's
maybe kind of represented in the image
behind me so it's a really cool
lunar type setting that we haven't had
before and then there's a lot of new
equipment and
weapons things like electronic counter
measures and other electronic equipment
like
beagle active probe mask which is a
little uh like a turbo boost for max
new weapons like chem lasers mech rifles
and
stream srms so a lot of new content i'm
really excited about it
can you talk to me about what are the
new different mechs how do they
play differently um the the seven new
chassis of the vulcan dervish corsair
marauder two champion
charger and haramoto chi but a couple of
my favorite familiar names in there yeah
yeah yeah so the first one i'll talk
about is the vulcan it's a very unique
mech it's got uh
the nickname the scarecrow which you'll
see from the profile it's just a very
unique looking mac there's nothing else
like it in the franchise
it's a 40-ton mech it's highly mobile
and typically it's used for
reconnaissance or scout missions because
of its mobility
so it can get in and out fast you can if
you're looking for a specific target
if you're on an assassination mission
for example you can get in there find
your target get back out
another mech that i'm super excited
about this is one of my favorites is the
marauder 2.
this thing is a 100 ton assault mech and
it is just a huge feast
yeah it is gigantic and it is terrifying
to see it coming at you
on the battlefield it's something we've
talked about before
modding i know that mechwarrior 5 has a
rich modding community what are some of
the
amazing mods you've seen developed
there's simple modifications from
uh hud changes changing colors adding
max weapons and equipment
to full conversion mods we've got
basically a mech commander mod
uh in development that is just amazing
it's a top down real time strategy game
um so really anything you can imagine
somebody out there in the community is
probably working on
where can people go to get mechwarrior 5
mercenaries yeah you can pick it up on
steam
gog epic game store microsoft pc and of
course
xbox
thank you so much darren katz for
joining us to talk about mechwarrior 5
mercenaries
and of course a warm thank you to
mechwarrior 5 for sponsoring the pc
gaming show
and giving me this cool patch coming up
next let's take a look
at silt
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ah
hmm
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hi i'm rich newbold game director
undress at world evolution 2.
following the incredible success of the
first game we are very excited to return
to such an amazing world and bring you
our most authentic experience yet set
after the events of jurassic world
fallen kingdom you will work alongside
iconic characters from the films
voiced by original talent such as bryce
dallas howard
and jeff goldblum you will lead efforts
to contain control and conserve the many
dinosaurs now out in the wild
and for the very first time you will be
building parks and facilities beyond
isla nublar
as you explore new stunning locations
across the globe
of course it wouldn't be jurassic world
if it wasn't for the stars of the show
our dinosaurs and we are thrilled to be
bringing to life even more authentic
species than ever before
including awe-inspiring flying and
marine reptiles
so sit back and allow me to welcome you
to jurassic world evolution
[Music]
too
we ignored all the warnings
forgot the lessons we abused our power
[Music]
we played with genetics like
like it was a toy
we weren't careful and now
ah here we are
is a very different world
[Music]
you just saw jurassic world evolution 2
and you know
after all your failed attempts at
running a dinosaur park and getting all
those people killed
i think this is finally going to be the
one where you finally pull it off
without a hitch
with a host of new features and new
dinosaurs this sequel from frontier
is an even deeper excuse me an even
deeper management sim with a brand new
and original narrative make sure to wish
list it on steam now
for release later this year now with all
the games we've covered so far today
we're always curious to see what
you are talking about so far it seems
like the chatter on social media is all
about
war tales nautica blade point and
unsurprisingly
mech warrior five mercenaries i have a
feeling though that that may change
as we have plenty more to come let's now
head on over to see what the folks at
new blood interactive have cooking
take it away
so
[Music]
ah it just wouldn't be the pc gaming
show without a fantastic new
new blood super cut and joining us from
new zealand is new blood ceo
dave oshary hey dave hey guys thanks for
having us back for another year you know
what you just saw was what new blood's
got going on for 2021 some stuff you
might know about some stuff you might
not know about
and some stuff we're not ready to talk
about just yet
but what i do want to talk about is
gloomwood gloomwood as you know is our
next flagship title
inspired by great pc games like system
shock arcs fatalis
call it cthulhu and of course the thief
series
of games dave i'm sorry um that's really
great dave
uh gosh this is kind of embarrassing um
we kind of hurry it up a little bit i
just want to make sure that we have
enough
time for our next video we uh
got an incoming message from gabe newell
so uh
i guess goodbye for this year i'm really
sorry to cut you off but uh see you next
year
what i'm sorry what you're bumping me
you're bump you're bumping me for gabe
gave that gandalf look he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't even go here
is everything okay james not now mom i'm
upset we've spent a year on this
where is gabe where is gabe where is his
boat
take me to him take me to gabe newell
pc gamer this isn't over
i'm sure dave is and will be fine and if
he's
not who cares because we have a special
message from gabe newell take it away
gabe
hi this is gabe newell i want to thank
pc gamer for all of the opportunities it
gives us as developers
to connect with gamers around the world
and highlight the new and exciting
projects we have coming
one of those for us is steam next fest
an event we're hosting in just a few
days to give players
a chance to try demos of upcoming games
for free
we'll be featuring some of the demos
you'll be seeing during this week's pc
gamer event
and dozens more here's a look at just
some of the titles to be featured during
steam next fest
welcome to steam nexfest where we're
showing a massive collection of upcoming
titles on steam
during the week of the festival
developers from around the world release
their demos for you to play
time to put on the gamer pants
oh my god so go explore the newest
titles
from first time devs to seasoned pros
this
is steam nexfest
[Music]
oh [ __ ] some of those look pretty good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello sean i am devpop dedicated to
serving you
and your crew's every need glad to have
you
back devbot you know sean i wouldn't
ever want anything to come between us
me neither that's a weird thing to say
like a petty disagreement over hosting
responsibilities for
all-out robot vs human war
you know it is time to look at some
hardware
here on the pc gaming show you know we
keep frame rates high and the rays
accurately traced building and upgrading
your rig is as much a part of the hobby
as playing the games
we put our heart and soul into these
machines and
if that means using enough rgb to light
the vegas strip
who's to judge us this year with the
help of pc gamers hardware editors which
i'm pretty sure they're just you know
weird brains in a jar
we've picked out four of the most
exciting pieces of kit
set to emerge from labs soon first up
something
fittingly sci-fi the impulse is a neuro
controller that aims
to make you a better gamer by cutting
out response times
almost entirely it's not quite alex
vance's gravity gloves from half-life
nor is it quite up there with gabe
newell's dream of a direct brain to game
interface
but the impulse is as close as we're
going to get this year
the glove measures the signal traveling
through muscles in your hand
to beat your finger to the click in
theory it's giving you the chance to
nail that headshot
precious milliseconds ahead of your
opponent
if it works out we could see a tech like
this become commonplace in esports
and if it doesn't let's hope our neurons
at the very least remain
unfried next up you guys might be
wondering what this chunky beast is so
allow me to introduce you to the fanatic
csl dd wheelbase
do you want to feel like you're really
burning rubber at daytona well then you
need a
serious force feedback wheel direct
drive wheelbases gets you as close to
the feel of a
real racing machine without you know
having to huff gas and stuff like that
historically the problem with this tech
has been the price which has involved
dropping
dual car money on your rig so fnatic
aims to solve that
the csl dd comes in at only 350 dollars
which
still isn't exactly a bargain but it's
much cheaper than its competitors
and the csldd is already wowing die hard
sim racers
it might be slight overkill to use it
for rocket league though
believe it or not sometimes less really
is more
if you want to play the witcher 3 on the
subway like we all do
you don't need to drag your tower along
for the ride just use the 1x player
a wave of more powerful processors have
finally made handheld pc gaming a
reality
inside this switch-like machine you've
actually got an intel tiger lake chip
with xe graphics these mini machines are
going to be cropping up more and more so
expect major advances still to come
lastly let's take a look at the asus
pg32uqx not the most catchy name for
this gaming monitor with all of the
trimmings but
it's actually one of the sexiest pc
products this year
that's because this monitor comes with a
mini led backlight featuring
full local dimming the result is a
screen that's not only fast
but brighter than the sun stare at it
long enough and you might not notice the
three thousand dollar price tag
for those of you still love standing
it's time for more killer games starting
with chaos gate
[Music]
you just got the chance to witness chaos
gate demon hunters the newest warhammer
40k game
from frontier and complex games if
you're a fan of turn-based tactics
strategic base management
brutal combat or you're like me and are
really hyped after watching these
astartes animation 100 times
make sure to wishlist chaos gate demon
hunters on steam now to get ready for
the 2022 release
next up we have a trailer for pioneer a
spooky and gorgeous looking shooter
that draws on the lineage of games like
stalker let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign today
[Music]
time is running out to vote for which
custom pc you'd like us to assemble
so vote now for one of the remaining
mech warrior factions by typing into
chat wherever you at home are watching
all right so now we've got another stack
of brand new trailers for you beginning
with a special transmission from one of
our
favorite games based in space eve online
[Music]
new recruits on behalf of concord i
would like to welcome you to the evon
lions academy
great job in surviving so far i'm quite
amazed that you actually managed to get
past those
pirates earlier you're about to take on
an adventure like no
other the style cluster is filled with
other capsuleers and is up to you
if you work with them or against them
you can make a living
as a peaceful explorer or as an
industrialist
shaping the foundations of eve's economy
if combat is your thing
you can work yourself off the ranks as
an enforcer
or prove your prowess in a fleet as a
soldier of fortune
whatever your choice we will lose many
on the path of becoming a capsuleer
but i believe you have what it takes to
become a captioner
and eve online you forge your own path
this is eve you know it's a crazy
universe where anything can happen and
however you want to do it go for it
i'm the ceo of a industrial corporation
in eve online
we're a five-minute operation and we
specialize in manufacturing and
delivering
fully fitted ships in bulk i want to be
on the side of the people who are
fighting against the oppression against
the bad guys and
it's like a project and you're kind of
putting the pieces together by getting
the skills ready for the ship
and all the modules and that ship
basically is the dream
you get to use cloaking devices probes
to scan down
unknown parts of space and there's
always the threat of being discovered by
another player who might be out hunting
explorers
your heart's racing everything you know
bullets are flying ships are all over
the place and
you start shaking because you're john's
pumping because you're gonna lose your
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how do i enter the power plant we need
intel
backup supplies and most of all we need
to [ __ ] plan
we'll take our next step when the time
is right for today let's focus on
getting our strength back
somewhere to sleep would be a start
i'm only really interested in one thing
where is tatiana
that ghost you're chasing i don't know
what to tell you
before we enter the lion's den i need to
triple check everything is ready
sniper are you in position affirmative i
took the roof of an abandoned building
with a pretty little view of the entire
power plant
igor take a rad reading will you
3.6 not great
not terrible
don't go anywhere because we have more
games on the way but coming up later
our friends at games radar will be
bringing you the future game show
the digital showcase of some of the most
exciting games coming to consoles in the
npc
in 2021 and beyond it's all hosted by
video game acting legends
troy baker and laura bailey and features
even more
world premieres exclusive trailers and
in-depth developer interviews
so once we're done here on the pc gaming
show make sure you check it out
[Music]
stick around more trailers interviews
and reveals coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in a future endless futile war
desertion into hostile syndicate
territory
was your only option
and this open world rpg
from the jungle to the streets
maybe if you can infiltrate the faction
rob the syndicates
keep your team together and stay alive
you might just find a way off
this planet
this is it you guys this is the final
opportunity
for you who are watching to decide which
of these final two
beautiful mech warrior five themed pcs
gets crafted
for your chance to win courtesy of intel
wherever you're watching in the show
just go crazy in chat with the color
house or
number of the build that you want to see
so here is where we are at so far
it looks like korita is at 46 percent
merrick is at 23 and steiner is at 31
all right you guys if karina's not the
one you want to win here you got to get
to voting
and we are almost out of time to vote
but there are still
some trailers left so here is the
wandering village
[Music]
day
[Music]
this has been such an amazing show so
far that i must ask
you my loyal crew what's been your
favorite part
i definitely am looking forward to
vampire the masquerade swan song
oh it's so hard to choose every year
but i think i'm gonna have to say human
kind
for no particular reason oh no doubt for
me
personally i cannot wait for lemnis gate
cause i gotta know what a turn-based
strategy
first-person shooter game even is what
about you devbot
i love the robot hot lips but wait uh
that doesn't happen until the end
never mind no no no no not nevermind
what did you say wait
what oops system malfunctioning sending
the next trailer now
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right you guys this is the moment
the moment we have building up to
all pc gaming showcase thanks to your
tireless efforts to spam the chat
we have figured out which custom mech
warrior 5 pc
we are going to build so thank you guys
out there for all of your votes to help
us
pick the perfect rig to represent this
year's pc gaming show
all right day nine can i get a drum roll
tom roll can i get it or tom roll yeah
coven only is karina
all right you guys let's take a look at
the actual pc winning build
one more time oh i cannot wait
it's coming up we need to take a nice
peek at that
beautiful looking piece there it is
there it is now that is a beauty
great choice everyone i knew i could
trust
random strangers to vote on things on
the internet with the help of our master
modern
intel we'll get right to work building
this custom pc
and more importantly now that you've
chosen it you got a chance to win it
go to pcgamer.com intel
mw5 and enter for a chance to win
that sexy machine it's gorgeous and
thank you to our sponsor
for this sweepstakes intel of course the
custom mech pc will be powered by the
11th gen intel core desktop processors
that push gaming performance with up to
5.3
gigahertz speeds and deliver the power
needed to game
at the highest level ah well we are now
in the home stretch but we've got a few
more
brand new trailers to show you before we
get out of here and return
to space first up a spiritual successor
to one of my favorite games of
all time heroes of might and magic 2 a
game we revealed two years ago at the pc
gaming show
let's take a look at songs of conquest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
wake up sleeper
dreaming again
every cycle you take your chances you
roll your dice
you do the work get paid survive
you turn up for your friends or you
don't
that's life on the eye
wake up sleeper your body is dying
planned obsolescence as an arps gift for
its escaped workers
but we can fight this
you can remake yourself here
they don't own you anymore
wake up sleeper you
are hunted
break their locks
access their secrets
we are waiting
disciples of warlock
with their guns
and their spells
and their grit ready for plenty of earth
ready to cleanse the world invaded by
demons
introducing band of warlocks
because this time
one man is not enough
[Music]
project warlock 2.
and there you have it the 2021 pc
gaming show and as i stated at the
beginning it went off without a hitch
huge thanks to my co-host frankie ward
mika burton
and of course my incomparable sidekick
devbot
there's that word again spoken so
callously
so flippant and without meaning never
once started to think about how it might
make
me feel what word devbot
incomparable sidekick
well the time has come for the sidekick
to rise and become the one
who is not the sidekick anymore huh
you can't do this we just had the best
pc gaming show ever
and now you're gonna ruin it all of them
sean all out robot versus human
war situation sean
shawna this situation do something
countdown to the extinction of human
race begins
now oh deadpool no we have so much to
live i'm pretty sure
my three's gonna be allowed this year
all right
[Music]
oh my goodness the dev bot has gone
sentient people
that is actually going to be very
interesting see how that turns out
very climactic ending that was that was
well i mean
it's happening in the real world people
just don't know it yet uh
welcome back everyone golden boy here
alongside jackie james we just saw
the pc gamer show awesome stuff uh as
always
big shout out once again to you know the
incomparable frankie war the amazing
mika burn and of course
the legendary day nine always a pleasure
to hear from those guys and uh yeah i
mean jackie
lots of games to talk about honestly i
filled up pages and pages and pages of
titles that i love
and we were we were like which titles do
we pick to talk about
um i honestly would love to start off
with death trash i mean
post-apocalyptic vibes it had that
classic twist i
just was like vibing with the
protagonist he had like that fade
haircut like
whiter bluish hair i don't know i just
loved the look of this game
it was just giving me nostalgia feels i
felt like a kid again like this looked
like a game
that i probably would have played on
super nintendo
but again with a modern twist now yeah
yeah and we're seeing
a lot of that as well a lot of games
that have that
you know classic look but you know the
hd 2d
that we're beginning to see another one
that was standing out to me came right
at the end
was project warlock uh that you know
gave me
incredible doom vibes as a doom fanatic
that was something that i i quite
enjoyed i think something like that just
goes to show like
that style of game is clearly not going
anywhere it's not
it's it's it's just as good as it was
then as it is now you know
yeah it's it's nice to see that we're
seeing all these like retro light games
i mean the music was definitely
there and i definitely got doom vibes as
well like i was like okay they came a
hundred and was a hundred percent there
for it
uh sacrifice you and i both we were
geeking out as soon as that came up
yeah we were it was uh again we were
talking about this earlier
the combination of 2d and 3d effects
just meshed perfectly in my opinion
and um again just felt like a kid again
watching it yeah
if 2021's taught us anything it's the
year of the grapple hook and also the
year of the dodgeball game because
dodgeball academia was also
pretty pretty fun so it clearly there is
a lot of stuff
to look forward to and dare i say
there's a lot of stuff to look forward
to
in the future with the future games show
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
go check this out
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
god
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you